morning Millennials good morning
Millennials welcome back to the morning
toast today's Monday July something and
I'm Claudia and I'm Jacqueline and the
last we spoke about it I was going to
see that apartment daddy sent you two
videos I remember yes and like that was
it and like that was not it it was just
like oh you know you want something to
be it so bad that you like are blind
that you'll compromise right and I was
like you have a cog oh I thought yeah I
thought it was like so great and then I
realize like it's so expensive and it's
like not even what I want and I'm like
so I decided to be smart and say no even
though I was like ready to sign like I
was making but I came with the deposit
but I feel like for you you feel like
you're in such a rush but technically
you're on track like a month I have a
good butt market is good the market is
to be moving but this is just like the
hottest time to be moving because like
people are graduating from school and
getting apartments and it's the most
expensive times like if you're not on
street easy every day you're gonna miss
out yeah but I found I found another
apartment thanks to an amazing sister
thanks to an amazing sister like an
amazing favor I saw this apartment and I
was like I saw it on Thursday and I left
for Phoenix Friday and I was like I
cannot not see this apartment like it's
it has about on your phone yeah my phone
it has a walk-in closet so I made an
appointment and Jackie went for me which
was so nice and she sent me the most
like descriptive detailed video like it
was just like when I saw it in person
yesterday it was like I had already seen
it right cuz you really did such a good
job with the video thank you and it's a
dog-friendly building and it's just it's
perfect it's a co-op so we do have to
get approved which is a little bit of a
process but I don't know who wouldn't
want me living in their apartment I'm so
clean I'm a family like I'm and I
totally gal I'm an ideal tenant and you
guys like are a young vibrant couple
you're oh there's your only going up
from here bring a lot of life to the
building you will and you know I feel
like you could be there for a long time
yeah let's go well it's definitely like
an older building in terms of the people
who live there but I love the woman I
love that I live in the building now
with like teens you're an older woman
look at your shoes you know loafers I
wore these yesterday and when I went to
the building me and Ben were like very
buttoned up you know cuz it's a co-op
like you gotta it reminded me a Sex in
the City when the doctor what was his
name Robert Miranda she's on the her
co-op board and Robert comes and I was
like I wish Miranda was on my co-op
board to totally accept me and like
another reason why
Miranda is the worst is because she
dumped Robert who was the greatest guy
so oh wait - I finished sex in the city
over thank God
last week and I was tell happy to be
done with it because really towards the
end you really get over carry and
Petrovsky like he is the worst thing
that ever happened to her and honestly
they were perfect for each other
she deserved him she deserves me to
Paris she deserves two-stepping job [ __ ]
yes you deserve to fall on the floor
into your people are always like big or
Aidan I'm like no Petrovsky they were
perfect for each other like they both
had this like non-committal life were
like they didn't really have real jobs
like but they had enough money to live
they both made bad joke yeah they were
both and it looks like they really did
they were perfect for each other
and when big comes and picks her up like
it's mad cute but like she did not
deserve him no she did not deserve him
at all so like I was just finishing and
then Miranda when it's interesting how
much they cut out on a and they cut out
the good stuff because it's like the
extra jokes that the storyline doesn't
need but it's like that's why we watch a
show right so I every episode I've ever
seen was pretty much on e and then
watching it on where did we watch it on
Amazon it was the full episode so
there's like five or ten minutes that
you miss like when you heard Robert
confront each other in the staircase of
their building that wasn't on a right
and so you don't know that Robert is
actually like bitter yeah right but in
the episode they make it seem like he
moves on so quickly right there's a lot
missing on e nothing
I agree but don't go through the trouble
of watching the whole thing because it's
it's so aggravating and it's just it's
members are watching in Nashville and
people literally we were if we were on
season five we were the burger episodes
there's the worst episodes where
screaming from our heads like through my
fish and Leia did see where she's so
annoyed and you know what the more I
watch as like an adult who is a rational
person logical the more I think like big
was like this bad guy who played with
her like he was very upfront from the
beginning I'm not really interested in
loving you if that's a problem peace and
the more I watch him I realize that
Kerry is unseparable and unsympathetic
like she makes terrible choices and the
same is true for when you re watch
Gossip Girl like Serena is one of the
worst characters of all time never makes
a good choice in her life and we're
supposed to feel sorry for her because
she's pretty like that's truly the only
thing she has going for her and Blair is
the real MVP
she works so hard huh hurt all to be
taken away one day just cuz she got a
little petty I don't I didn't never
rewatch Gossip Girl because I don't say
what I think that I could take it no it
Jamie the man I was watching and
everyone loves Serena I was like this
girl is nuts
she makes horrible choices and like I
don't feel sorry for her like she makes
her bed and now she has to sleep in it
she just thinks things are gonna go
better for her because she's so so being
of Serena did you see the video of Ryan
Reynolds and Blake live in a Taylor
Swift concert it was so cute basically
they went to the Taylor Swift concert
and in her song gorgeous it starts with
like a baby saying the word gorgeous and
the baby is their kid so she they knew
the song was coming and they were
recording it and they were so excited
like screaming it was literally the
cutest video of all time it was it was
really cute but watched through another
lens it's also the reaction you have
when you're at it let out of your cage
right what does new say it was like I
was happy for her but then I know that
when she goes home she's to go back
under the trundle I actually I have to
be honest seeing them more and more as
watching that video is starting to chip
away at the theory stigma it's in a cage
so if you guys know we're talking about
we just have this theory that like Ryan
Reynolds it's like the most controlling
husband and like doesn't let Blake
Lively work unless he's like unless he
literally wrote the script like he's
like so controlling I think because I
read one blind one time that was like he
was telling her what today I didn't even
read it I'm pretty sure Olivia told me
about it no I but it was it was what the
blind wasn't that she lives in a cage
it's that like Ryan Reynolds was being
controlling about a script that Blake IV
could do so it wasn't like so extreme
but now now I just see it through the
lens of like her being a prisoner of her
own her husband but I agree I'm starting
to see a new side of them yeah I like
being wrong I would love to be wrong I
think you think now that she's a mom
like that really takes up so much of her
time and it's like how can he control
her when she has a mother right
mothering there's not enough time in the
day when you're a mom to be controlled
by someone else right I'm so hungry
like my stomach just dropped I'm sorry
also we both look so like blase today I
mean it's because we have such a busy
day we have like the most corporate day
we get well we're recording a very
special podcast after this with medicine
is javi who is literally like I'm
obsessed with her MJ from Shahs of
Sunset we're gonna go to her hotel room
we're gonna do a podcast only cuz she
couldn't make the live show but you
still want to come on and we're gonna do
just like a fun Q&A I'm excited for
podcasts only I feel like
are such good episodes put your hair up
you're comfortable you don't have to
worry about like what you look like when
Dean and I filmed our podcast for
patreon she's like never done a pot
she's just a regular girl you know it
was still funny when like regular folk
do a podcast they don't even know the
intricacies right she came over and she
was like so do we just record this on
your phone I was like no I have
equipment I like got her all miked up
right and she was really great and it's
funny cuz she has a really manly voice
for someone who's like so small and
girly well it's not small and she really
was great we had such a good time taking
a trip down memory lane and reliving all
of our old stories like we tell these
stories that we have just to each other
and it's getting kind of sad but now
having this platform where we could
share with the masses it was perfect for
us and our friendship really neat and I
heard really good things about it
speaking of speaking to the masses I
went to Phoenix and I just have so many
thoughts tell us sister do you know that
Phoenix is like just as far as LA it was
five hours I did not know that and you
don't get a lie flatbed which is just an
abomination but something about that
later Nexus as far as like Dallas in my
mind no it's like what it's the West
yeah I thought I was in the Midwest but
no it's just wet and you aren't Pacific
time I didn't realize that I thought
you'd be on Central Time me neither I
had a 24 hour day that's great because I
woke up the same I flew to Phoenix the
same day as my show so I woke up at 5:00
in the morning did my show my show was
late at 10 o'clock and I ended up going
to bed at 2:00 a.m. Pacific time which
is 5:00 a.m. in New York time so I was
up for 24 hours and I didn't nap Wow I
was just a real pleasure to be around
how did it go the Phoenix toasters
looked lit as how the very game the
Phoenix toasters it's just so funny you
really never know what to expect from a
town because you don't know like I don't
really we're not really in tune with
like the demographics of our show so so
well some of them but I'm gonna be
honest Phoenix I'm not so in tune right
and so there's always like a small
community when we go to a different city
you just never know how busty it's gonna
be and there was a pregame hosted at
this girl's house who by the way I
recognize her house and I know why she
put her whole renovation in the HGTV
Facebook group and her house is so cute
I mean her and her boyfriend or husband
hosted a pregame for the show and
literally a hundred people showed up it
looked so fun ahead of bartender it was
open bar and I wanted to go but I had
soundcheck so but I didn't want to like
like I wanted him to know that I like
knew about it yeah
so I ordered pizza first of all how much
you think three pies a pizza costs well
it's tough because in New York like
where we never buy a pizza it's just
like a dollar but I went to get pizza
for your birthday I took $40 with me for
two boxes and as I was sitting there and
they're making an obsolete how much is
this gonna cost I didn't have anything
else right and it was $40 oh wow for two
boxes of New York Pizza so three boxes
of Arizona Pizza but the place was
called NYPD New York a pizza Department
oh so it's New York Pizza okay
$35 seven D Jackie and I it's called a
hundred places to get them to deliver
like it was so difficult and then I
finally found a place there like okay
$70 I'm like 17 they're like 7 D I'm
like what that's great why didn't call
Domino's because I wanted them to
actually eat it and then I'm gonna cease
really and then a lot of the girls told
me that the pizza was bad so you should
have called Domino's because they have
all those deals on but Domino's is like
literally disgusting no it's not it's
feeling I should leave just smells bad I
had looked on the same block as a
Domino's for two years and I have been
once I know I was desperate I think you
would actually really like I'm a thin
crust girl I'm a real cheese gal I know
Cinna Stix you know they have other good
stuff
remember we went we went like we went
once we were so hungry and drunk
literally for two piece of pizza it must
have taken over an hour because he
fainted by the sight we were sitting in
Domino's like no because they only do
pies which is why for Phoenix
it would whatever I said yeah I thought
it looked good I thought everyone was
just complaining for no reason but this
girl Caroline I'm holy cuz there's like
nothing there like a night on the town
is like right ordering Domino's so like
I only think of it so fondly and
high-end you know okay well you have a
skewed vision cuz Domino's is trash what
was I saying oh so she hosted a pregame
in her house it looked so fun they all
like working from 6:00 to 9:00
the show started at 10:00 I didn't know
before I went on that that where I
played is the biggest comedy club in
America
what because most comedy clubs are like
250 to 300 people this was 550 what's he
called
stand-up live and it's the same
franchise I'm doing in Palm Beach which
is all they're the same size that's
amazing I know it was really so you
alright well you're amongst the biggest
comics in America and I met Michael yo
do you know who that is it sounds for me
if you see his face East Oh familiar
he's been on a bunch of shows he was
definitely on Chelsea Lately he is like
a real comic and he did the show before
me so like when we were in no dress
like passed by one another it was just
like grabbing alcoholic yeah yeah you
know us comics it's a very small circle
but that'll be great yeah and it was
nice because usually I leave the night
of the show but because the show is at
10:00 usually it's like at 7:00
I wasn't like in a rush so the mean
green must have been three hours long
because I was just talking to everyone
like I was in no rush like I don't have
anything I was just like going to bed so
I was like just talking to everyone and
relaxing it was just great any good
meet-and-greet stories any memorable
characters no actually the the thing is
it's so funny because when I go to these
shows like the people who work at these
venues are used to like comedy fans like
normal people who have like a drink or
two they're not used to the toasters who
show up out ready they show up already
black out and then they have to meet the
two-drink minimum so they just keep
going and they're like not used to it
like these bodyguards who are like
literally 400 pounds they're like man
I've never seen anything like that I'm
like I know I tried to warn you
that's crazy your shows make me excited
and scared for cam toast they make me
excited because it's been a good time
they make me scared cuz like liability
and it's like they are gonna outdrink
like I can't keep up with that no me no
but that's what I was talking to a lot
of the girls on the mean we like cam
tous is like it's obviously gonna be fun
rayji but like I'm really looking to
like a wholesome time and like to do a
lot of active ease I want to go the
distance I don't want to just like black
out for three hours and fall asleep and
then we come over yeah and be hungover
ya know I want to sip a wine and have a
nice buzz the whole time while also
doing the ropes course preach it preach
in a verse because safety first safety
first I have to do the ropes course
especially after OC we should recreate
like video there's an amazing ropes
course at this camp and it's gonna be so
fun but because we have such a busy day
of businesswomen's special we need to
jump into the fast five stories that you
need to know before you wake up and take
a bite out of your morning toast we
added a sound effect we can't hear it
but you guys can and I'm really excited
about it to work okay first up this is
news that came out on Friday and I just
feel like we have to talk about it
because we need to [ __ ] all over it okay
Nick Jonas and Priyanka Chopra are
engaged after two months of dating yeah
whatever good for them um I hope that
none of you out there actually believe
this news this is this is what I was
saying the other day it's like it's so
funny that we live in a world where like
there are some people who really think
Nick Jonas and Priyanka Chopra are like
madly in love no totally I was in a car
full of people on the way to Old West
this weekend and we're talking about
this very thing unlike somebody everyone
was offering their own explanations up
and one that I heard which you know I
appreciate the creativity that they're
clearly dating and that he sped up the
engagement to take the the light off of
Demi so people would focus on something
else I'm like no people can focus on two
things like we're in the car talking
about all of it right we're right that
there's such a flawed theory and I
appreciate the effort but there's a lot
they're not even on good terms Nick and
Demi really yeah that was like one I
feel like even if they say they're like
family it's like when something big like
this happens they'll be there for each
other agreed but it's a flawed theory
because it makes you assume that this is
a real relationship when it's not right
no no it's definitely not I just think
it's funny how they think we're so dumb
you know um totally and what we were
watching before our show on Thursday
what's so funny that little I don't know
what it is it's like it's a digital show
what is it you know series on these
Instagram and I think it's also one
youtuber it's a little longer but it's
necessary realness with Morgan Stewart
and it's always really fun and because
she's great and she's like very like us
like Whitby but she didn't
edited really well so it's a she's funny
and then they make her even funnier they
did a segment on Nick and Priyanka and
it's so funny and he's right before they
got engaged she was like yeah I'm not
buying it but she can't really say that
as much as weekend yeah no that's but
that's what I feel like it's probably
difficult about being like talking about
celebrities are talking about Brava
shows but then also being on Bravo or on
a it's like you're limited in what you
can say right but I think you know I
would pay that price to be on Bravo
oh yeah we're not complaining don't
worry we'll take a Bravo show and
speaking of Bravo we have double
confirmation now that Annie Cohen knows
about knows about potatoes Dana ran into
him at a restaurant last night I'm so
happy that she like in real time she
texted us okay basically one of our
toaster listeners said she met an to
come in Thursday I watched Upton's live
and she I had the balls to be like by
the way you should watch and go on the
morning shows it's a great show and he's
like oh someone told me about that show
last week this morning oh this morning
and we were like what and Cohen knows
about the toast
hello then our friend Dana was at
Morandi last night which I know isn't
any Cohen hotspot cuz he writes about it
excuse me in his books all the time and
she said first she sent us a picture of
her and Andy and by the way they look
like old chums I'm like are you a both
have a lazy eye that's why Emily dinner
look related they really did because in
their picture their believe each check
the exact same amount about they're both
cheesing really hard to one side and
their dana has a lazy eye pictures and
so does Andy he talks about in his book
so he's they're both like and they look
like twins they really do so I I was
like oh my gosh you guys are the best of
friends ask him if he knows about the
morning shows I gave her all the bullet
points millennium Morning Show social
media morning show to be better one
sheet weight gave her the one sheet and
she mustered up the courage and was like
have you heard of the morning toast and
he was like yes I just heard about it
last week so I just feel like if we
kissed and his story is straight yeah
you know if we keep inundating him with
it like if anyone were to like run into
Andy or just like see you on the street
and be like by the way you should watch
the morning to us we don't even want him
as a guest I know him to develop the
[ __ ] out of the show totally so your
mission as toasters is anytime you see
Andy Cohen just mention the morning
toast oh that's he think that way he
thinks it's the most popular show
prejudice which it is but we need to get
on his radar
yeah so when we're already there we're a
blimp now I'm les blip a word blip we
need to become a blip totally okay so
those are thoughts in Nick and Priyanka
they don't fall for it even if they get
married white picket you know what's so
funny boy and a girl like they're still
faking is that every news outlet had to
use the same picture of them from the
Met Gala to announce their engagement
because they've literally been together
for a week they have like four pictures
together and like this is the only one
right it's a good one now she looks
great but they just look so silly to she
looks great but she looks like Carmen
Sandiego in that trench coat like
solving a crime or she looks like
Harriet the Spy no but it's cool
no it's glamorous it's a glamorous Harry
at the spy but she's still hurried spot
it looks like a picture like that that
you cut to people and you've pasted them
too from Parent Trap when they rip them
right but it's like as if you put her
with Meredith Blake in that picture
totally do you see that yes I did
okay so honestly even though enews
steals a lot of content from us I have
to give them a big pat on the back
because they're their social team is
very in tune with what's necessary and
they got Elaine what's her name her real
name the woman who played Meredith Blake
in The Parent Trap Lane Hendricks and
you know I love that her tits like she
really leans into that character like
she knows that was the highlight of her
career and she's not gonna like be
ashamed of it like she leans into it she
comes in on my Instagram and I posted a
picture of Meredith's play I love her I
love her and so they did a really cute
video of her like pretending to be
Meredith Blake and honestly like as much
as I think that he is in a way they
really did a good job
no and it you like as long as they're
doing good work and stealing our good
work it's okay
but ii they just start relying on us
it's not cool what do you think people
think that there's like this alumina
something around the fact that
everyone's getting engaged in five
minutes these days okay
people think that they're all related
and I actually don't think that they're
all related unless everyone saw how much
attention it brought to Ariana and Pete
and they want to be in that boat but I
do think Ariana's Peter so you need
I think Ariana and Pete are crazy in
love I think they're like just such
passionate people and they love each
other and like they just want to spend
every minute together going to Whole
Foods wearing high ponies and
thigh-highs in the winter in the summer
did you see her Surrey shopping with
machine young Kelly no dude no ho
Machine Gun Kelly I know who he is like
yeah can I tell you about machine guy
Kelly sure so when I was in college I
was interning at a company and they did
this thing where they would bring in
like celebrities every now and then it
was like low-level celebrities and
Machine Gun Kelly came ones and like I
was my job was like to run the Twitter
for this big company and they Machine
Gun Kelly like his fans like I'd never
seen people like nobody ever spoke about
our show but these Machine Gun Kelly
fans like we're insane so crazy so he
comes literally people from all around
the world came like nobody ever came to
the show that you have to pay people to
sit in the audience but now they like
literally real people are coming his
real fast it took me up until now to
figure out what internship yeah they
were very eclectic like they had lip
rings and spiked hair and tattoos and
it's it's an interview the show so they
would like sit and chat like like this
he got up tore his shirt off was
screaming in the audience and I'm like
who is this guy then he's on that song
with Camila kebaya which is the best
song ever a great way to launch her solo
career then he's in a movie what movie
with Pete Davidson that's why they were
together shopping at Whole Foods it's
just it's too much for me and I know
that the trajectory of Machine Gun
Kelly's career is not really about me
but somehow I feel like you know when
you're there in the beginning it's about
you yeah you severed him from the
genesis is that the right word yeah yeah
so I think Arianna and Pete are one
thing they're crazy in love and they
just want to like be together same I
think Haley and Justin is another thing
I think that they really and like I know
my theory was kind of a joke but I
really don't think that it is I think
that they have both become really
religious and like even though yes
there's a lot of things that go on in
Hollywood and it's not all you know the
way that we picture it but I think that
their religion has really brought them
together and they want to be man in life
yeah the blonde suggests otherwise but I
do
I think they each have kind of differ
intentions but I think at the core of it
like that's really what it is because
like their religion places so much
emphasis on marriage yeah I don't know
they're confusing no I'm I'm choosing to
see the good and then with Nick and
Priyanka I think this is like classic PR
thirsty right I don't no one's talking
about us the only problem with this is
that the two of that makes no sense
together if it were like the only thing
also is that they're just started dating
so if they wanted to make this
believable they wouldn't have to get
married they would have to get engaged
for another year like the fact that it's
going so fast makes me question if it's
really a setup do you know what I mean I
cause if it was a setup they would want
to be believable normal people they're
spotted once and then a couple times
then a year later maybe they get engaged
like this doesn't make sense
I think it's because they got together
and still people don't believe it and so
their PR move like isn't working it's
not sticking the way that they wanted
they think that getting engaged will
really turn the tide on this one but I'm
not buying it no no nice - credit card
and I'm not buying it if they get
married I will I'll I'll stand down if
they get married have six kids and are
married till the day they die in 60
years I will still not believe that they
ever had affection for each other if
they have a happy long marriage with
grandchildren and a house with a white
picket fence I still won't believe that
they are truly in love they could
literally there's nothing they could do
now to make me believe that this is real
they could come on the toast and explain
themselves fair because we've had a lot
of changes of hearts amongst people
Liam Liam Lockett is a perfect example
of your heart can really change like
just because you think you know someone
you don't you do not Leeanne Locken who
is the villain on the Real Housewives of
Dallas came on our show and honestly the
day before I couldn't sleep I was so
afraid she's really scary just oh also I
think the number one like I was excited
for Leeanne Locken no matter what but I
think I really changed my heart and my
mind on Margo joseph´s when she came on
the show oh my god up until that point I
was so teamcity like I couldn't even
fathom we were brainwashed because Ziggy
had just come on our show and we were
like yeah and honestly I like them both
I like them both but I really hated
Margaret when I met her and I was like
wow when she came on the show she's a so
lovely so normal so down-to-earth and
then she's been nothing but absolutely a
gellick towards us and I love her so
much
that's
however the toast you guys know it's
really true just when you talk to
someone that's why I always say like
people who hate me I understand
I'm very annoying like I do not I do not
disagree with anyone who hates me but
someone who hates me if they were to
have lunch with me they would love me
totally maybe we'll say okay next up
Alex Trebek's signals that he's retiring
from jeopardy in 2020 it's time it's an
end of an era guys who do you think it's
gonna take over it's having an meet Ryan
Seacrest I know you're gonna pay and
like I'm not down it's gonna be scary
gasps key shut up quiz eat Rebecca
member I know like he's not really
relevant anymore but no but that's it
that's it yeah if jeopardy is in tune
with what's necessary and in moving
jeopardy to the 21st century
they're gonna have to hire Scot Rogowski
which is upsetting because I despise him
and he came on our show and was really
rude to us however this isn't happening
until 2020 so maybe you know okay quiz
yeah quiz each are busy McGuire quiz
daddy general right and like I'd be
happy for jeopardy jeopardy because that
means like their social team and their
management team like they know what's up
and they know what's good but I just be
annoyed because I you know when people
they get successful like it's really
interesting to see like how they treat
others you know yeah like a look at us
we have a number one morning show in the
whole world and the co grounded we are
but I don't think he the problem is I
don't even think he was trying to be
mean I think she was just like naturally
like I'm tending you like towards girls
you know he just didn't take us
seriously and it's like why and he
wouldn't have said that test if we were
boys that is my favorite thing to say
these days like would you say that to me
if I were a man yes because I had an
experience phones okay let me explain
myself okay because I need explain
myself my world is really torn on this
one and I have to be on but I'm
understanding let me let me speak okay I
was in the airport Delta Sky Lounge
which is very prestigious Club I don't
know if you guys can get it and I was
very busy I was downloading my episodes
of southern charm and you know it
downloads still [ __ ] slow before the
plane and you got to download it so I'm
downloading and then Margo calls me my
sister who I haven't seen in two months
and is abroad in the Middle East okay
but to everyone in the Sky Lounge they
don't know it's just the prettiest girl
on your phone so my headphones really
tangled up in my bag and I know Margaret
had to ask me a question so I lowered
the volume really low and I'm just
talking to her quickly and I know that
it's annoying that I don't have
headphones in but like give me a break
the guy sitting seven or eight feet away
from me he goes excuse me and I thought
he was gonna be like are you girl with
no job and I'm like yes I and he was
excuse me I was like yes my autograph
he's like he's like can you put
headphones in I was just like I was so
just like not expecting that and I was
like oh sure sure so then I go to Margo
I'm like Marco I'm being yelled at in
the sky lounge I have to go and I said
it really loud so I wanted him to hear
me and let me get let me set the record
straight I'm not what's the right word
I'm not naive like I know that it's
really annoying of me and I'm not
discrediting that but and if I saw
someone I was doing it I'd be like wow
that person's annoying but I would never
be like excuse me can you put in
headphones like that's such a rude thing
and I know that if I was like an older
man this old man would not have said
anything to me
then watch was lesson in old man he
wouldn't have said anything to you you
know what if I was a fellow old man no
but if he was like an old woman or a
young girl like he wouldn't have the
balls to say something no it's not but I
don't think he would feel like he could
talk down to me if I was like his gender
or a year yeah I just felt like he
totally thought he was above me and I
was like a dis [ __ ] guy and I did a
whole Instagram story thing about him
and I get on the plane he's sitting
literally right next to me and I didn't
even think we were on the same flight
cuz I left the Sky Lounge like while we
were boarding like a normal person and
he looks like the last person on board
no dick no that's also like a cocky man
yeah to do right I'm the first person
I'm the first person because you're so
worried cuz you're a woman that it's the
imposter complex that you won't have
over and I didn't say patriarchy is
gonna take my overhead bins and he'll
make space because he Cherokee will work
in this paper so that's just like that
was really upsetting and people are like
you're you're an ass like I know it was
annoying at me I'm not discrediting that
I understand but if I was with another
person having a conversation we would
have been way louder than me and my
phone it's just thought that's true just
a thought okay I could see but I also
could see how like your fake screaming
in the sky lounge
put in headphones completely but you
don't know my story like this could've
been important I both he could actually
hear your conversation and my sitting
into labor I don't even remember it was
so early it was literally 6:00 in the
morning okay but it was like 3 o'clock
in the middle east which is why I had to
take the call I understand well Alex
Trebek is retiring and you know what I
want I want to be up for the role I
would like to be considered ok here or
for the regular tortilla okay okay ready
okay so I'll be a contestant you'll be
Alex Trebek
and let's say the category okay so I'll
say I'll make it something up Alex I'll
take literary fictional characters for
200 please no you will take famous
couples throughout history okay for two
hun Alex okay hold on let me start from
beginning welcome back to heal a fortune
I'm real afford I could go unreal a
fortune and win okay that's a good oh
yes I talk about beaches am yet because
I don't have to go welcome back to
jeopardy I am your host
Jackie Trebek welcome Claudia Thank You
Jackie it's a very excited to be here
I'm a teacher from Iowa and my students
they're back home watching me they're
really excited
well hello students so Claudia pick your
category hmm I will take famous couples
throughout history for 200 please great
choice
this famous couple name rhymes with
grossie Josie and guy guy guy guy god
guys Thank You Claudia no you'd be good
at it I would be about to wear that
place every day I'd be happy to I would
wear my grandma's shoes yeah I think
that should be really good jeopardy it's
like makes me feel so stupid I never
know any answer it's like on a good show
I might know one that's yeah we need to
play like teen jeopardy yeah pop culture
Japanese yeah we might have that I
should have reality TV jeopardy I would
win a million me too or I would host it
and also make a million dollars just
have to work a little bit harder for it
totally now I'm thinking I'm getting
really getting jeopardy and Wheel of
Fortune confuse because then we don't
need a banner white because they go on
an f1 after each other it's seven
o'clock jeopardy 7:30 will a four to an
eight o'clock bachelor that will
apportion is just luck like you don't
have to really have some luck but it's
also you have to be good at this game
but it's not a smart thing it's just
like being good at filling in the blanks
you know it doesn't require much smart
no but you do a lot of crossword puzzles
like it should be fine oh that's true I
do by the way I've been traveling so
much and I always buy Us Weekly and
people because they have good pictures
and they also have a crossword puzzles
and I was on the plane yesterday doing
in US Weekly and I'm like damn this one
sounds familiar
literally because I've been traveling so
much in the same week I got the same
magazine twice it's not crazy Wow cuz I
knew that I didn't know a dove what you
said what sound do doves make
No so I was like how do I know this
it was ku how do you know oh because a
crossword puzzle yeah that's what it
took so weird how do I know that that's
so you should get one of those little
crossword puzzle books they don't make
those for celebrity ones they just make
it for the real ones and I cannot do
like the New York Times read for you
know like totally 1996 play that won the
Tony you know totally okay next up
inside Liam Michels epic and beautiful
engagement party with Zandi rice cute
yeah she looked really pretty it was
thrown by joanna garcia Swisher their
best friend
i love her so much so Lea Michele is
feeling the love all around her over the
weekend the Glee star and singer
received an unforgettable engagement
party where she was able to celebrate
with friends family and fiancees Andy
Rice the outpouring of love from our
friends and family who showed up for us
today and through us the most epic and
beautiful engagement party we could have
ever asked for was truly so incredible
Lee as shared on Instagram stories Z and
I love you all and are forever grateful
close friends Stephanie Levinson and
Joanna Garcia Swisher helped execute the
party that featured Ashley Tisdale
Hilary Duff
jamie-lynn Sigler Becca Tobin Billie
lourd Emma Roberts and Evan Peters in
attendance wow what a crew yeah it's
just so interesting when you think of
Lea Michele's like um career career in a
nutshell because like she's made it so
far but she's really not that famous or
successful um and like just in terms of
like financials like she's been on a
couple really good hit TV shows that had
important implications for pop culture
like one was right I mean they were both
frying Murphy but like one good was Glee
and that was just like will be one of
the most important show of our
generation and then the other was the
screaming kids it wasn't it wasn't as
popular but it was a Ryan Murphy month
so it had like a lot of like glamour to
it and it was a star-studded cast right
so that's where Emma Roberts and Billie
lourd can play and I'm surprised ariana
grande wasn't invited
well I mean maybe she was just busy but
she was also really on it for one
episode and there were there was a lot
of talk about like the divas just not
clashing well anyway I didn't understand
that there's like Naya Rivera and Lea
Michele they did not get along but that
I don't understand because they both
came into the show as nobodies and you
should be grateful to be on this set but
like totally and Michelle and ariana
grande are both big personalities like I
didn't understand they must be awkward
that when you both start out as nobodies
and like someone on the show that just
takes off so
more than the other like I feel like at
some point it's gonna become really
awkward between Lily Brian horn Academy
Mendez cuz they're like best friends
because they both started out as like
okay equals dad I agree but I don't
agree on my Rivera Lea Michele Lea
Michele had a way bigger part oh of
course no I mean I Rivera was out of
control for even thinking she was even
close right she just like happened to be
a likable character on the show but I
don't think she was intended to be that
like oh me neither and I think that they
faded people out and they also like kept
people relevant who I think the audience
liked most that they could for her yeah
I think nobody exchage Anil it er didn't
say anything but I think people really
started to like her the more that she
spoke so they gave her like a full role
like she's in New York right when they
all moved to New York so I think she
thought that she was just as good as Lea
Michele and just as big and honestly
like if you didn't want to ruin your
career you shouldn't have commented mean
things on Kim's Instagram right honestly
that your career literally that was it
those it I mean I'm sorry but you're a
mom Congrats so are you by the way
literally she put up a sexy picture the
other day and I was about to comment I'm
sorry like literally exactly what she
wrote but I just didn't feel like
getting like starting drama you know
totally sometimes it's just it's not the
time or place anyways I'm happy for
these two and you I like their little
Hollywood crew me too and I really truly
genuinely and my soul only want good
things for Lea Michele I know you do but
I think she deserves the world she I
mean like I feel like she's doing okay
she is and you know why in that magazine
that I bought twice they did a big
people did a really good like in-depth
article with Cory Monteith's mom and she
spoke really highly of Liam and she just
it was like such a sad article cuz like
it was just it was really heartbreaking
and that she lives in like this small
town and that Corey like would send her
money all the time and like and she's
like he was soul was too good for like
the treachery that is Hollywood which is
so true when Steven was here we talked
about that article uh-huh and there was
just so much in there and it was also
second I could tell he really comes from
like a normal grounded family and it was
like one of the saddest articles had
ever read I agree I hope that they stay
in touch that's just like how Michelle
Williams just got married and Heath
Ledger's parents are so they were really
hard for ya and I never thought I would
love Michelle Williams so matter but
first of all the great German second of
all shutter island' she's the wife oh my
god I really need to be watch a movie
but yes and I've never had a dress
shutter island in the world that it has
played on the show because
there's probably like the most high by
thing we've ever talked about it's
really just spurred so much
international conversation right and I
feel like the toast has really been
doing that a lot recently yeah and it's
really good for our souls I agree and
that's actually a great segue into our
fourth story speaking of goodness for
your souls goodwill will launch a trendy
boutique to court thrifty millenials the
resale market is booming in April
reports surface at the industry which
swell by 2022 and hit an estimated forty
1 billion dollars resale shopping may
even outrun traditional retail and
goodwill wants in on the success what's
the strategy Millennials love of
Millennials love of thrifting so
goodwill is launching a new boutique
concept to do just that partnering with
YouTube influencers and students at IIT
it's not a bad idea and it's not they
should be partnering with us but ok
according to thread ups resale report
millennial shops secondhand more than
any other generation that's because
first hand is so ugly these days that we
have to go to the archives for cute
clothes attracting younger customers is
not only a major priority it's a
necessity the company's average
customers roughly 45 years old says Katy
golf Stig president and CEO of Goodwill
Industries of Greater in New York and
northern Jersey but to achieve that golf
stake added company execs had to make
some real changes the traditional
second-hand shopper at the Goodwill
store is skewing older so it's time for
us to disrupt that this is interesting
it is but you know I have such mixed
feelings because like as much as I think
like grateful I love a company that can
evolve
I like six months ago cleaned out my
closet right before we went on a trip I
forget what it was in December it was in
December yes I was like I wanted to
Florida for five years
oh right oh my god I went forever and oh
yes why I had eight trash bags full of
clothes that like I wanted to donate so
obviously what do you when you think
don't you think good Widow right so I
just like I wanted to obviously like be
thirsty for the fact that I was doing
goodie then I put it on my Instagram
story and I got like so many messages
about how corrupt Goodwill is and not
like people who work there go through
the clothes and take stuff like take the
good stuff from people who actually need
it and like leave the dirty t-shirts or
the dirty jeans and I was like holy [ __ ]
and so like now I've been like when I
move I'm gonna clean out again and I'm
gonna go to another organization so I'm
like I'm caught in between a rock and a
hard place you know I agree no good deed
truly
oh here's the thing like I feel like
this what's her name Katie Gulf state
history isn't too much what's necessary
the resale market is huge and this
sounds like a great idea but like it
goes against what goodwill stands for
like but I think what the point is is
that it'll if I do a little bit more
high-end so they'll make more money and
then reinvest in goodwill and hire more
people to steal their stuff right but I
don't I don't think that they need that
like she should start her own resale
company and she has this vision but like
goodwill it's like it's just goodwill
like it's doing it is this gonna be
high-end stuff like I think it's just
gonna look more like boutique II when
you go out you boutique yeah I say but
did you
I say boutique but boutique II I don't
know whatever it seems like when you go
in and you won't be sifting through
trash bags like right you know you know
more of an experience you don't sit
through fresh bags that good will they
hang it up they hang it up but it's not
like you don't something shopping this
will be more of a shopping experience
which is cute but like I feel it takes
away from what goodwill is about right I
don't know I feel like I'm more loyal to
the Salvation Army are you because I've
had such positive experiences donating
and buying snouts donating and chopping
it that's really good night and like my
beloved Campbell's boxers that are no
longer with us remember those yes came
from there and I just I love like I just
love the Salvation Army I think it's a
great I feel like they really are like a
wholesome organization so you think but
just wait till a toast are coming or
wait till I get a blind about it you
know right anyways I'm gonna keep up
with the stories I find it to be very
interesting and I look forward to seeing
what they do and I hope that they hired
more let me know moral people yeah no I
just I love when a company is in tune
with what's necessary so like if this
works them good it's very intriguing so
it's necessary so I'm here for it fifth
and final story Nikki Bella officially
cancels wedding to John Cena again quote
I've ruined everyone's fairy tale okay I
watched these two are out of control
these two are out of control and I
thought so until I watched total Bella's
last night and I Canali it was the
season finale and I understand so much
of why everything happened and why Nikki
Bella feels the way that she believed
that it was a PR set up for the show
I do not
I feel like okay so this is what
happened she they broke up and then they
got back together because John said that
he wanted kids and she thought that that
was gonna change everything so they got
back together so when he went on The
Today Show and was like why was gonna
tear the first breakup but I'm saying
was that filmed uh in what time it is
the season finale no loser always after
today's show okay oh that was filmed oh
so they were filming the whole thing
they were filming the whole Jase season
finale must be from like a month ago
right
two months ago because also it's been
very quiet recently cuz I feel like they
wanted to put it out this way and no one
knew if they were together or not and
then she said on a live stream that like
he's yeah so what they got back together
after he said that he wanted kids and I
think she thought that would like fix
everything because it fixed a lot of
things then she went on her back to
Paris which looked lame is and she was
miserable and the whole thing was
miserable it was like fake Kim
Kardashian bachelorette party except it
was miss and she like was in terrible
mood and I guess she was like also
unhappy during her engagement party
she's doing all this planning for the
wedding by herself with Bree Jon's not
there for any of it it's just indicative
of what their life is gonna be brother
and I think she was just like really
unhappy like in herself and as a person
and she said she was like depressed
while also having like there's a lot she
was like I felt so much pressure like
I'm Wonder Woman and he's Superman and
like we came together and ever it's just
like once it's a fairytale like prom
king and queen
and honestly I could wander back in the
cheerleader I felt like I perpetuated
that I came here and sat on this show
that you guys need to get back together
and like she felt that pressure
she learned our crab so like I think she
was really trying to make it work and
she doesn't she thinks that jon is a
great man and like she could see them
getting back together but I think like
she's a little sad in herself right now
and she needs to work on herself for the
past six years it's been the John Cena
show holding husband and Bree said it
best she was like he's been so focused
on making an amazing career for himself
which he has and in that like she lost
the woman of his dreams
totally so I guess since they got
engaged a year ago they spent 30 days
together like in their home that's when
she says last time yeah so I can
understand why it's not all perfect yeah
oh my god that's so tragic and imagine
like how bad it has to be how sad you
have to be to break up with John Cena
right like after you spent six years he
said he wasn't gonna marry you that was
okay he married he's gonna
and he's the one who really wants to get
married and uh Brie's husband asked
Nikki he she brought him gentleman bryan
danielson he was like why can't you guys
just postpone the wedding like what's
the big deal
and she was like john doesn't see it
that way like he's very like we're here
or were they like honestly decision a
little bit of a nutjob I think that he
is a nut job but after six years like of
being with a nut job
you you understand and it's warm to get
a job lifestyle right and it is John
Cena so I couldn't understand why she
would like make exceptions for him yeah
but I think she's really just coming to
her and I think when she was younger she
had the same complex that we do but
wonder when one Wonder Woman Superman
like let's make it work we could be the
queen queen and king of WWE and so
that's what really motivated her and
then they like fell in love and like she
couldn't mansion life without him and
then all the pressure where you put on
her like I feel bad I'm really sorry
I feel bad I'm really sorry she's in the
car and she's talking about how she
needs to be alone but then she said but
I love him so much and I miss him
already like the day after she comes
home she's that are like living at her
sister's house sleeping on a pull-out
couch brie is a really good sister so
like that's how bad it has to be that
she'd rather stay at Brie's house on a
pull-out couch in her mansion with John
Cena
why doesn't he have a second bedroom I
think the second bedroom is a pull-out
couch because like oh my gosh I need the
bed no but brie is like a really good
sister cuz honestly this is it's like
the Nikki show like the light ace but it
always was
well it's really crazy because it's so
crazy how fortunes change like for the
past three years like Nikki has been on
top of the world dating John Cena like
she's been like in the best shape of her
life and like brie on the other hand I'm
pregnant like her husband is seriously
injured she's pregnant and like things
have slowed down for her but now it's
like the season finale her husband went
back to Wrestlemania and then one and
he's like at the top of WWE again when
Nikki feeling so terrible
right here engagements over but they're
really so there for each other and it
goes back to what we said last week
about family yeah like it ceased and
what's so interesting is everywhere they
go every city that they stopped in like
they're like we're here for this and the
other thing and then they go out to
dinner and their whole family is there
like the mom the brother they went to
Paris the mom and the before a
bachelorette party in the mom and the
brother are just there like for support
they went to New Orleans for
Wrestlemania the mom and brother are
there when brie and Bryan moved to
Phoenix I thought it was the family
lived there too and now they're all in
San Diego and the family's there too so
they're really so interesting because I
feel like it definitely has to be hard
to be a twin and you're both like famous
and you both have a show and you both
have instagrams like I feel like there
definitely has to be some element of
like competition
because twins are tough it's like a
tough time I mean I think you're always
being compared to one another so in an
effort to like make yourself feel more
unique you become competitive and I've
always admired the fact that they really
are so there for each other like
sometimes it's all about break and stuff
and most of the time it's all about
Nikki
but that's so interesting about their
family I didn't know that no I'd they
have a really nice dynamic and on the
one hand you would think they'd be
competitive but on the other hand they
were like each doing exactly what they
want to do like Bree has an amazing
husband and like an amazing family and
like I feel like she's really embraced
this next stage in her life and like
Nikki is at the top of her game like she
could go back and compete whenever she
wants like I feel like she is she wants
that so I feel like I actually really
complement each other and it's very very
nice I just think total divas and total
Bella's was a really inspired choice by
e.i suggestion program I never watched
total divas but now I'm like all-in on
total Bella's and I have to be honest I
think a lot of it had to do with John
Cena
you know I was a lot of that had to do
with train wreck and you could be my fit
my CrossFit Queen
I want to CrossFit world total divas
someone got married Natalya like was
crying and it was like the best episode
ever and they literally couldn't stop
fighting and I think that Jeff getting
forced and that's when I started
watching I mean I cried at last night's
episode now that I think about it and it
was so cute so when Bryan they talked
about I didn't never watched I didn't
know how bad his injury was but they
have all the footage so they're showing
us the montage of how he worked so hard
to get back to where he is and he goes
to Wrestlemania and he fights he wins
and he's already so happy and then Bree
comes and shows him a picture of their
daughter watching him on TV and he
started crying and I had a tear oh my
god now I need to watch I love crying I
know I really really like the show and
I'm glad I'm happy for a mostly Michio
they need it before we wrap for the day
let's quickly talk about southern charm
right because we had a final second part
of the reunion or third second second or
third there's no surgeon I thought this
season could have used a third but
apparently didn't because even after the
second and we were just saying like yes
the second was intense and Ashley and
she's so crazy and blah blah blah but
like I found the first episode to be
more interesting of their reunion
because the second was all obvious like
the clearly insane Catherine is
justified like thank you Lord but like
the first episode between the nuances of
the characters was more interesting yeah
I thought the first episode was good I
thought the second episode like I didn't
really get as much as I wanted like I
really wanted more like escalation like
I really
and I didn't want Catherine to do it but
this is what I was saying look I really
want to join the cast just for once he's
in because I would like to physically
like hurt Ashley on Catherine's path but
if Catherine does it like the judge will
see and like right she's she's justified
in her restraint but I don't what do I
have to be restrained for it everyone
needs me ready I want to be the [ __ ] out
of her like we break her in half in half
I just sit on her she's so small and
fragile she's so small and frail like
when I kept cutting to her and her
makeup artist like that poor girl like
that was just like tragic and I really
it really bugged me how she kind of got
off the hook when they're like oh she's
manipulated by Thomas she's brainwashed
okay
this might sound mean of me I know
you're about to say it's not mean she's
31 years old she's lived she chose to
move to Charleston you don't choose to
move and and stay there when Thomas
literally wants to get rid of you and
you're the one who's brainwashed right
she's she's not like when Kathryn met
Thomas she was a child she was so naive
in mountain village and he took
advantage of her and it took her so long
to get out of that cycle like she came
to Charleston a grown-ass woman a nurse
like seeking out this so I am NOT gonna
accept the fact that she's brainwashed
unless she literally like sat down was
like please brainwash me but attend in
which case she still chose to be very
much because she's a grown one oh but I
took all these people six years to
understand that Kathryn was literally
manipulated and brainwashed by Thomas
Ashley who's a grown woman has been in
it for what six months and everyone's
like is she's brainwashed has seen the
show run is technically a medical
professional yeah so I'm not buying
that's the scariest part of all Thomas
not being there was really unfair
frustrating because yes I understand
like he should be fired because he's a
sexual assault er but he also has done
some terrible things and he should be
held accountable and he sat at six or
seven reunions now while everyone was
going in on Kathryn and he never felt
that brunt right and he like he deserves
to be tried in the Bravo Court which is
the most accountable court right like
yeah
Court is bad but you know the punishment
you get you serve your time you do the
crime you serve your exactly time but he
deserves have to know how it feels to
have everyone against McLean and the
including Cameron including Shep all day
with her today it was so bad he was but
he needed to be like yeah I wouldn't
needed to not to be biased because this
situation is insane right when it's like
petty girl drama I feel like it's easy
for
you know like stay out of it and just be
like a true mediator but these are like
moral issues and kids are involved in
like the legal systems involved like
Andy at some point like has to step in
you know I agree and he does a good job
of knowing when that is but I just felt
like there's not like the reunion wasn't
surprising to me no me nothing was said
that was surprising Ashley is a cycle
but that wasn't surprising and I'm just
glad that things are working out this
way for Catherine it makes me really
excited for next season because finally
it's an evening even playing field yeah
and I can't believe Kevin and Chapel
[ __ ] up and I'm really ship then me
too
I think they're really cute together I
think they have something like you could
tell I feel like she might be the like
the girlhood girl for him like she's so
strong yeah she's not gonna take a [ __ ]
like yes she doesn't take Thomas's [ __ ]
right and Shep's [ __ ] is way less than
Thomas's [ __ ] um honestly I find Austin
to be so hot no same and like what's so
crazy to me is that on television like
Austin and Chelsea look like
star-crossed lovers like they're meant
to be together in one day that they will
be but after watching this ring and
there is nothing between them and then
finally the things that she said about
him like hit me and she's like there's
no going back from that I can't believe
she said that he didn't pay for her like
a bunch of meals and what she said is
like she was being so shady she was just
like I didn't grow up the way that you
didn't like I literally can't relate to
someone who doesn't like want to work I
told her after when Naomi went and he
was like is there any ambition in this
group whatsoever and they always say
there's ambition not to work ya know
that's exactly what it is and what's not
being said is that they're like reality
stars man but like for a guy especially
in like an old-school traditional town
like Charleston like to not have a real
job like I totally get what she's saying
and it's not like he's like trying like
he's just like a weenie no totally and
this isn't gonna go on forever and like
you need to start something now so that
you have it when this goes away because
eventually like all good things it will
die really really hope that he goes
forward with this beer I think it's the
best idea I've ever heard man I was
watching him all season like he's
obsessed with beer like a beer
aficionado it would be like you starting
a Chipwich lying yeah and I said it was
really good he wakes up every day and
does beer samplers he doesn't even like
start chugging Bret hands of beer so I
mean used to work in the beer industry
so it should be a breeze for him yeah
next season if he's not shilling his
beer yeah it's a lost cause the logo was
cute too on the cup the whole thing is
really it has the makings for success
and I don't drink beer but I would trust
Austin's
um that's what we have for you we're
about to go record excuse me a podcast
episode with medicine is javi and I'm
very excited this is the morning toast
the marna moment morning the blending a
morning show right yeah that's it um
make sure you watch we live stream on
Facebook and YouTube to make sure
subscribed on YouTube and like us on
Facebook
both at the morning toast our Instagram
is lit a spark lots of drama always
going down at the morning toast also on
Twitter the morning toast less drama but
still premium content if you're not a
member yet of our Facebook group which I
think we're like pretty much well
they're letting it select people because
it's it's really big it's got 30,000
people and this is like for our real
hardcore listeners just like chat about
and we have so many requests like I know
I wouldn't say this isn't the time yeah
but if you want to just try and get up
in the morning toasters it's lit that's
it everyone have it an amazing Monday I
hope this helped care a little bit of
your Monday blues we have a very busy
day so we have to go we have to go but
we'll be back tomorrow with young I
folks from southern term Savannah
thank you much for nice again oh my god
oh so few I'm so excited
you